[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the distinct pleasure of being here with
matt taibi who
is a reporter for rolling stone and sub
stack
many of you will know him for those who
don't you should definitely
look into his writings he has been
utterly
fantastic and consistent for decades on
some of the most difficult topics
that there are to report on i would say
he is a singular voice in journalism
today
welcome matt thank you so much for
having me on brett it's a
it's an honor um well i'm not quite sure
where to start i have to tell you 2020
is proving to be
a remarkable year and i think you and i
are both
seeing a disturbing and complex
picture emerging and i suppose the thing
to do is just to figure out whether we
can make any useful
sense of it yeah i mean i
i i think um the the first place for me
that that's interesting is
uh i think a lot of us in journalism um
are coming around slowly to the fact
that we we missed
some big stories that took place uh
on campuses a few years ago um
you know yours the obviously the one in
yale
uh but really you know we've heard from
academics over the years about
certain things that were going on and we
i think the the reflexive
reaction among most people in the press
and most of us are kind of liberal
leaning
in our political orientation um
was to say okay well that's a right-wing
talking point
and you know we're going to have trouble
selling that story anyway if we try to
do it
and so let's not even bother
and uh so there was a combination of not
taking it seriously and then there's a
little bit of like cancel culture
already working in
into the thought process with
journalists because we just knew that we
couldn't get that past editors
right um but now
you know this is this has come into our
business in a huge way
in particular in the last couple of
months as you know so
um you know people like me i think oh
people like you an apology
for coming around to this late if
anything
yeah well i have a uh a rule of thumb
when it comes to such things
which is i welcome anybody
without the need for an apology who
recognizes that they got it wrong
and says so my feeling is there's a
point at which
you didn't get it and this is true for
all of us and then there's a point at
which you do
and you know you didn't see it as close
up as
we did on campuses but anyway thank you
for acknowledging that there was
something to see
and that it wasn't seen by you and
others early enough
i have to say from my perspective you
know it
uh it emerged and became very apparent
and there was this experience of trying
to alert people to what was coming
and there were so many ways of
dismissing it as it's
a free speech issue it's a college
campus issue
you're making a mountain out of a
molehill you're a grifter all the things
that get thrown at you
and now we're in a situation where i
don't know
what kind of blindness you would need
not to see that the thing that happened
at evergreen and elsewhere
is suddenly uh in every institution that
we've got and
spilled out into the streets but it is
the
least satisfying i told you so
imaginable
i mean i'm just watching civilization
burn because we couldn't make this point
you know a few years ago and
wow what are we going to do now that
it's at this scale
it's really interesting i i think there
is going to be some blowback
um in the media world because
obviously i think what happened and i'm
only just starting to do the research on
what happened in academia
because i think that's now the important
background for all of us who are trying
to figure out what's going on
in institutional america
but the you know the things that are
happening
in the journalism world are kind of
similar
to what happened in academia there's
this schism
between people who kind of believe in
the traditional
fact-finding mission of the news that
um that can't be uh
linked to any kind of ideological uh
imperative and then there's a new school
that's coming up
and there it's being expressed by people
like wesley lowery
who were talking about something called
moral clarity
um which you know is very i think a lot
of young journalists really believe in
and they they believe in it for
different reasons and i think some of
them are just very socially committed
um and they really believe they want
their work to be impactful
but there's a there's a lack of
understanding about what the purpose
of the old model was and
why it was good for audiences and for
the institutions themselves
um and i think only now
uh is it starting to dawn on some of the
people who are kind of in the middle
like what those changes are meaning uh
and
um so i i do i have a little
bit of hope because and i didn't a month
ago uh
but but i'm starting to see people
within a lot of these institutions
um you know say things that i hadn't
heard before and and you're seeing
voices like
uh matt iglesias at vox who
was kind of on the other side of this
issue um
you know come around and i i i don't
know i i'm hoping there's sort of a
reckoning
within the media role although you know
who knows how
successful that will be but uh what i
mean what does it look like
to you from the outside well um i'm
fascinated to hear that you have hope
i'm thinking that you know with an
hour's investment here we should be able
to kill that off without the trouble
so yeah i i i i mean to be honest with
you matt
i've been an admirer of yours for a long
time uh since the financial crisis and
your courageous reporting
about that and i do think i mean
you're gonna see what i'm seeing
soon and at that point this is a
you know it's a break glass in case of
emergency
moment for the republic i i just see
almost no decent way out of this if we
don't thread a very particular needle
but i do see what you're seeing i mean
you know maddie iglesias is a
classic example he did come around to
his credit he
acknowledged that he had gotten it wrong
but uh i'm reminded
a little bit of remember the boxing day
tsunami uh in asia
oh uh yeah there were all these videos
so the thing is tsunamis were not
regular enough um in the indian ocean
for people to have a sense about what
they were
and you know most of these people had
not been living on the coast for
generations
when the water receded people walked
out they looked at the fish flopping
around on the
the sea floor that had suddenly been
exposed and it was all very curious
until the water suddenly came back and
there are just all these videos of these
people just getting
completely uh engulfed in
a tsunami from which they never emerged
and i have the sense that the hope that
you are seeing
with people waking up in journalism i've
already seen this movie
i know about the little glimmers of hope
and i know what washes over them
and uh we're there so
there's now going to be a phase in which
and i think we saw this in the harper's
letter there's going to be a phase in
which people who thought
that they were safe or that this wasn't
a big deal
are suddenly going to recognize that
they have no mechanism
protect themselves from from the
movement
that the quality of the arguments the
movement is making are not high but the
quality of the strategy
is it's spectacular and so
it's it's it's got this viral power to
it
um and you know one of the only reasons
that i
i feel like i was a little bit more wise
to it maybe than some of the other
people in the business because i spent
10 years of my life in russia i went to
school in the soviet union
um i remember a lot of these thought
patterns
you know i don't have a terribly
distinguished academic river one of the
few things i do know about is russian
history
and um you know the
ideas can be dangerous you know they
they they can be more dangerous than
really anything
and i i i think the
you know there's an imperative that we
have in in reporting and
it's very reinforced by twitter which is
when uh you veer off into a topic that
the majority of your colleagues decide
is not
important or not as important as
something else in the trump era this
this comes up a lot like why are you
looking at this when we have to deal
with trump
um you know there's so many more there's
kids in cages
you shouldn't be paying attention to x y
and z um
and as a result things that actually are
really important
often get short shrift and i i do think
i think you're right this this whole
thing
is is really about uh it's about an
intellectual freedom it's about the
values of
uh the enlightenment it's considered
about the the sort of core
ideas of the american experiment are
now under fire and um
you know there's there's a lack of a
willingness to
look at what that means or what that
might mean going forward i think because
people just don't recognize
how serious it is and and it's
again it's similar to what happened in
russian history people thought
that this little clan of you know
super motivated bolsheviks were never
going to go anywhere because even within
the relatively uh small minority of
socialists who were very active
they were considered you know nuts but
there they had a
a way of thinking that was very
difficult to counter in an institutional
setting
and this is kind of a similar thing i
think and
people are seeing this that you know
once once it gets into it
into an institution it's just really
difficult to oppose like
you know the people don't want to be the
person
to stand up and say i'm against
anti-racism measures or
i'm against you know the expansion of
the
equity the diversity equity and
inclusion committee
um because it just sounds bad and they
don't want to risk
the the you know possibility of public
public cancelling
as well well a couple things uh
one i heard a little bit of hope bubble
up there for you you said it's very
difficult to counter
i think if there's one thing we know
it's that it's impossible to counter
the way we know that is that no
institution
resists right best examples in terms of
let's say a college
that that resists is the university of
chicago and it's not a shining example
it's barely ahead of its
its competitors so when you have
something that washes over every
institution
you know that there there isn't at that
level
a solution and i'm not arguing there's
no solution possible in fact
i want to talk to you about a possible
solution uh later on in the podcast but
obviously
um but there's a there's a clear pattern
here
you don't think that this is serious
until it comes for you at which point
it's too late
right it's like that formulation and
uh you said a bunch of things i i want
to bring into the mix here
one is you say you're familiar with some
of this from russian history
in part the parallel to russian history
is a little misleading
because it's really chinese history that
is the
relevant example the mechanism the
social mechanism of action is much
closer to the chinese version of this
and um you know a lot of the parallels
are just
incredibly close and then there's
obviously parallels to the the french
revolution
as well on the reign of terror but um
but you know it's not going to be any of
these things exactly
it's going to be a new version the real
question for people like you and me i
think
is does this process that we are
watching
unfold in 2020 land on that
list of uh remarkable tragedies brought
on
by movements does this land on the list
with the bolshevik revolution
with the nazis with the cambodian
revolution uh with the rwandan genocide
do we end up in one of those or is there
some conceivable way
out of this uh
yeah i have no idea i mean it and
you know obviously those movements were
more violent to begin with they were
they were taking place
in um more open
uh more openly
destabilized political environments all
this this one's pretty bad as well
uh but so far the penetration
of this has almost entirely been
intellectual right and bureaucratic
um and when we talk about cancel culture
what we're usually talking about is
people losing their jobs
and then the accompanying problem of
people being afraid to speak out
um you know it's not yet at the level of
people going you know being
dragged off to basements and put up
against the wall as they did you know in
the
in the early days of the soviet union or
you know thrown at the ditches or
whatever it is
um so you know it's it's not that yet
but you know just in the last month
we've seen so many headlines suggesting
that
institutional america is already
almost completely consumed by these
ideas and we saw yesterday i saw you
tweeting about this with the
the federal government you know uh you
know is that is adopting
ideas that are you know frankly crazy
right
uh and it's it's very troubling you know
the the july 4th letter to open letter
in princeton which i'm something i'm
looking into now
like if that could happen at princeton
um and it hasn't happened yet right like
it
like the the things that they're asking
for in that letter have not yet been
approved but um you know
if that if the person who is speaking
out against that can be denounced by the
president in a place like princeton
which actually was one of the few
universities to adopt the university of
chicago principles that you talked about
um then that's a significant blow
right i mean the the it speaks a lot to
the
the problem that's um you know that's
going on across the country and you know
as a reporter i'm finding out all kinds
of stuff that i never knew
like if you're an academic now and
you're applying for a job
you know in probably half the cases you
have to submit
a statement to hr
with your sort of diversity ideas
and that's a prerequisite before your
application even
gets to the department that might even
be interested in you for whatever the
subject matter is
so this idea of having like this these
political commissars
uh in the middle of um
of you know sort of every level of
intellectual work in this country i
i i think it's just people don't
recognize the extent to which it's
already happened
um and yeah you know from the
journalistic
perspective we have a long way to go to
to get people to understand that
yeah um one thing i want to just adjust
about what i heard you say earlier
you said that it was about the
expression and
enlightenment ideas and
in one way i think it is about that from
the perspective of those of us
defending those things because we know
how important they are
from the point of view of the movement i
don't think it's about those things
it's almost purely about power over
material things and
the ability to speak openly about what's
wrong with this plan
the ability to invoke something like
science in order to demonstrate that a
claim
might be false the ability to appeal to
normal
rules of due process in order to
establish
a claim all of these things have to be
disrupted in order for a movement based
on fictions uh in order for it to take
over
so i i think uh the um
the i believe he was an ex nsa officer
william binney
described many of the uh the
uh structures that were put in place
after 9 11
as a turnkey totalitarian state you know
the idea being that the structures were
in place but the key hadn't been turned
so it didn't feel totalitarian but it
could at any moment
and this movement actually has that
element to it where it is disrupting the
things that would allow
you to get in the way of its power grab
but the key hasn't been fully turned yet
it's you know
why do you want to get rid of the police
right
well there's an excuse for why you want
to get rid of the police but then
there's also what you're going to do
after the police are gone
because the police are really the
mechanism through which all of the other
mechanisms
keep people from just taking what they
can
so i i guess as bad as things are
for the things that are very important i
don't think i think
eliminating those things is a means to
an end and i i
worry about about not only the
disruption of the essential
foundational stuff but the end that is
ultimately being pursued which i don't
think most of the people participating
even know about
yeah i think you're i think you're right
about that a lot a lot of people who are
marching who are protesting
and think they're talking about one
thing and
maybe there's a minority of people who
actually know what it's about it's about
uh but the important the important thing
is what's going on
institutionally and you know both in
terms of
the sort of explosion of new
administrative staff that
has taken place on campuses but
increasingly also is taking place in
in companies like media companies um
there's sort of new decision makers who
are inserting
their imperatives into the work right so
even in even in media we're having
situations where like the
the intercept right which is one of the
most liberal
uh media companies there is
you know there's a there was a strong
push to put in the charter
of the organization that
its journalistic mission was to advance
anti-racist causes now they haven't
quite
they gone there yet uh it they they sort
of
took a little bit of a left turn before
they they went all the way there
but that's something that's being
pressed in a lot of media companies
right now is this idea of writing it
into the mission
and um and that's
more important i think than how many
people are on the streets
it's like is is the institution now
fully captured is the is it already
demonstrated that the leaders of these
institutions will respond to
letters and calls for firings by
indulging them
right uh and i think as you pointed out
in pretty much every case
that's already been proven to be the you
know true right so
until until somebody starts standing up
and and
you know resisting some of these things
um
and showing a way to do it it's just
going to spread to
everything you know the big big tech
corporations big media companies
actually you know
academia already um so yeah
it's hard it's hard to know what to do
yeah so i don't i mean i do think
some of us have demonstrated how you
resist and it's not
a pretty picture you know my wife and i
were both
driven out of tenured positions that we
thought were secure and we discovered
they weren't um that said
we're surviving and we're not the only
ones but there's a limited number of
spots
for people to famously get ejected from
an institution
and make it in the outside world it's
just not it's not a
a program that can support all of the
people who need to stand up so that's
really frightening
i think it gives people a false sense of
hope because they see an example that
works out and they think okay maybe
that's the way and
it just can't be but um
but that said the real problem is not
that nobody stands up or that there's no
way to do it there is
and you know it's a learning process
right every time i
uh look at a tweet and i look at the
button
that sends it i think is this the one
right is this the am i about to end my
ability to earn a living by hitting that
button
um and so far it hasn't worked out that
way but it could at any time
so the problem though is that no
institution
can resist and so yes the intercept
had a the intercept had a frightening
encounter with this thing
it did not oh it's ongoing it's ongoing
and i mean i should say for my audience
you wrote an excellent piece about this
being widespread
in uh journalistic institutions and it
is
absolutely worth the read i would
recommend
everybody sign up for your site and look
at what you're writing because it really
is like the front lines and it's
so well described but the point is okay
the intercept
showed some sign of being able to resist
but the way the game works all of the
institutions that show no sign of being
able to resist
topple then the ones that do show some
sign and some inclination to resist
have called attention to themselves as
needing particular pressure and higher
quality tools brought to bear
and ultimately they all fall so what are
we going to do
when all of the voices that make sense
exist outside of the institutional
structure
because if they had stayed they would
have been compelled to go through this
uh this struggle session kind of
nonsense
um you know what happens when the
institutions are all captured and
everybody who knows what's going on is
no longer part of them well
it depends on what field you're talking
about because in journalism
it might end up being a positive process
because i think what we're seeing now
look there was already a huge collapse
in trust in traditional media in fact i
would argue that was one of the major
factors that got donald trump elected in
2016
um you know journalists rarely talk
about this
papers like the new york times rarely
talk about it but trump
really built his campaign around
campaigning against us the people who
are covering him i remember i was one of
the people
in the you know following him around and
he
sort of organizes speeches around the
press
as a representative of a corrupt leader
that doesn't speak to
the ordinary person and that process has
been
uh growing on both the left and the
right
for a couple of decades now it's been
sort of
a curiosity for me to watch uh you know
on the right you started to see it i i
would say in the early 2000s and then
especially after the occupy movement
um and and particularly with the bernie
sanders campaign there's been a huge
amount of disaffection
on the left too so the the authority of
institutions like the new york times
uh the washington post cbs
nbc msnbc cnn
they are they've already crumbled just
just as
as consumer operations they were already
in a bit i would say
basically in a state of failure uh
before even this
problem started to rear its head in a
big way
and what we already started seeing um
prior to this year was that independent
media voices including people that you
know very well like joe rogan
um were becoming hugely successful
just by not being that you know
because the audience now and i'm seeing
this with my own
site a lot of other independent
journalists are seeing the same thing
people are so um so disenchanted with
the uh politicized
tone of media institutional media that
they're they're looking for anything
that isn't that
so i i am i'm sort of hopeful that new
institutions will grow out of that and
that that has been a little bit the
history of
of this business you know it's not it's
not like
academia where you can't you can't just
wipe out princeton and
and all the ivs in another day build a
whole bunch of new media companies
um so there's a possibility that we're
going to build something better
but it will just take a lot of energy
and then what's going to happen with
those institutions once they get big
enough
is the problem you know so right now we
have this model where
there's no alternative big institutions
really
but there's a lot of voices who are sort
of growing
in in import um but they're all just
sort of individual people
i don't know if that's sustainable as a
as a replacement for what we had
in the press but um you know i don't
know if that answers your question but
it's a thought
it does but i i cannot resist pointing
out where i think this
goes because again i mean you even use
the word hope which at this moment
that's uh
um that's audacious let's just say um
here's the problem is that those of us
on the outside
there are two phenomena that i think we
need to pay attention to
one is that even the joe rogans of the
world
are dependent on the institutions of the
world
right joe rogan brings his
message and his guests to the world by
uh
things like youtube youtube
which has no accountability
definitely has this movement inside of
it on the market
all the time has incredible power to
wield tools that we don't even
understand
as outsiders to it and there's almost
nowhere
to go right you can abandon ship and you
could go to some platform
that um is
not subject to these kinds of pressures
but then
what happened well okay then you're
grouped with all of the
truly noxious stuff that also is not
welcome on youtube
and so you get tainted as alt-right or
worse
so kind of damned if you do in damned if
you don't and
the other factor that i want to point
out not only are there these
institutions which have this revolution
on the mark within
every single one of them but there
is the very real sense
that there is a censorious instinct
marching in our direction and it's
knocking off people and some of the
people that it started with were truly
terrible
right and then it's come to people who
are much more
uh in a gray area and you know it's
beginning we can see it even
experimenting with people
that there's nothing wrong with at all
right
all they are is abrasive so you know
james lindsey found himself
frozen out of his twitter account the
other day
right and it's like okay it was sargon
of akkad
two years ago and now we're at james
lindsay how much longer is it before
it gets to me frankly i mean i think
they would have done it if they could
have and the problem is at the moment
it's still it would be very awkward uh
you know
james lindsey is still on twitter so
apparently that's um
that's still not within the power of the
movement but of course it would love to
get rid of james lindsay because he's a
huge embarrassment to them because he
just simply says flat out how their
strategy works right so um
between the institutions that have the
ability
given that there's no real public square
the quasi public square that we have is
owned by institutions in which the
uh the revolution is on the march or the
uh the counter-revolution as it were um
and we see this thing experimenting with
how
to come for those voices that you're
describing who are
independent and might constitute some
kind of a you know a renaissance in
journalism
or an equivalent space by being
independent and not subject to an
institution
yeah you're right you know and i now i'm
checking myself for the optimism because
you know actually when
you talked about the people that came
for the noxious folks first i mean i
think we're talking about probably alex
jones just was was one of the first big
ones
um when that happened i was one of the
few people in media
who popped up and said hey you know this
is not necessarily a good thing
i think you have to look at what this
means for the rest of the business
uh today it's going to be alex jones and
if this mechanism
proves successful just by its nature
it's going to start looking
for the next thing it's going to decide
ben shapiro is next and then it's going
to start looking around then there's
going to be a
a process where groups are going to
start demanding that
we take the extreme version on the other
side off
to compensate for this person and it's
going to narrow the field progressively
that started to happen and then
additionally right after if you remember
with the alex jones thing
some of the platforms started to uh this
is the height of the russia mania
they started to zap pages that they were
calling
coordinated inauthentic content
um and some of them were
just regular old you know sort of
alternative media sites who
happen to be deemed
inauthentic by facebook and some other
of these big platforms
and i i tried to get people in the
business interested in this problem
which was that
uh the press traditionally
uh got its independence from
having its own distribution at least
print journalism did right so the
newspaper
in a locality built its power up over
decades
uh by uh having its own trucks
uh by having its own distribution routes
its own sales points its own paper kids
even
they were the only people in town uh in
the area who were able to reach all
those
millions of people and so that's how
they had their power you couldn't take
it from them uh
but in the internet age that vanishes
overnight
distribution is now wholly in the hands
of a couple of companies basically uh
the overwhelming majority of people in
this country get their
news from google or facebook or twitter
and so what happens if these companies
start
making sensorious decisions which which
is what they were doing
and i i was amazed really at the lack of
interest in this topic
among people in in the press i mean i i
grew up
uh you know my father was a reporter i
grew up around people
uh my first internship was the village
voice so
i i remember being people like nat
hintoff and wayne barrett
like the the the standard position of a
journalist
in the 70s 80s and 90s
was to be hypersensitive to any
possibility
of censorship or control over us
as an institution and that spirit has
completely vanished
from from the press like people people
don't even in fact they're act
they're actively asking to be controlled
more
uh if you even see any op-eds about this
subject at all
and so we're in a situation now where
you know people are being removed or
deranked or
shadow banned or whatever it is
constantly there's no transparency about
it it's it's effectively
a um you know a media regulator
uh that yeah you know that is unelected
and doesn't answer to the public at all
and uh yeah it's a very serious problem
because you're right
you know for all of joe rogan's success
at any minute
you know somebody could say yeah enough
of that
you know uh and you know he'd be reduced
to
i don't know what you know sending cds
through the mail to people you know i
mean it could
that could happen right and uh we are we
haven't
seen very much of some other layers that
actually will come into play here
so first let me just say one of the
things that is
most disturbing and i don't hear talked
about enough is that not only is there
this
desire to uh eliminate certain
perspectives
so that they just simply can't be voiced
where anybody can hear them
but it's also rather arbitrary
right i i can tweet that men are not
women
i won't get tossed off twitter i think
the only reason i won't get tossed off
twitter
is that i can pull the biologist card
and
certain people would you know would riot
in the aftermath of me being tossed off
for that but
megan murphy's gone for saying that and
so
i guess the question is what exactly is
this rule
that some people can say it and some
people can't like what universe do you
think that's going to result in
um so there's the arbitrariness which
results in
uh you know the inevitable outcome here
which is just
there's going to be favoritism there's
going to be this is going to be pure
myth making we're going to decide
certain perspectives are okay certain
people can voice
other things this is going to create
advantages it's just it's every value
that we hold dear evaporated all at once
but as far as the layers go
yes there's twitter and youtube and
facebook and instagram and
reddit and all of these properties but
then there's also the layers below them
right there's there's mastercard
and we've seen this in the past there
are certain instances actually
before the current cancel culture
era in which we have seen the mastercard
uh uh piece pulled out
so i remember early in wikileaks before
they had been successfully
uh portrayed as a republican
russian asset in that amazing story by
the way but anyway yeah
well i want you to say more about that
but let me just uh finish it out here
in the early days of wikileaks there was
a point at which wikileaks
to many of us looked like a
very positive force that was doing
something very important it was bringing
transparency to these
really despicable
processes and it became impossible to
donate to them
right i did donate to them at one point
and then there was some point at which
it became too complicated to do
and so how much of a win was that
against wikileaks that suddenly
the fact that mastercard couldn't be or
things and then there was another one
you know totally unrelated
uh daniel maybe his name is daniel
siebert guy who uh
um chemist who actually isolated the
hallucinogenic molecule in salvia
salvia which is a legal hallucinogen
which he was um
distributing suddenly it became
impossible to buy from his site with any
sort of normal currency
so my point is there's a there's a
fail-safe underneath the
um the platform layer which can be
pulled out from under everything and
then below that there's another one
and i have a feeling in the end we're
going to discover that net neutrality
was about something we didn't really
understand that in the end the
ability of isps to
take certain people out of circulation
will be invoked if nothing else works to
silence them
yeah that's interesting i i hadn't
thought of that
the all very possible uh
and uh you know we we haven't gotten
there yet it probably hasn't been
necessary but
i think the embarrassing thing is it
hasn't been necessary
because we just haven't seen oh
anything like a wide-scale rebellion on
the part of the people you would expect
it to come from i mean
you know the the people in maoist china
or soviet russia who worked in the press
they had an excuse
for not raising a ruckus about certain
things
the thing that's always bothered me
about journalists in the united states
is you don't even really need to offer
them anything
to make them conform uh
there's no particularly even any special
benefits that you get
um from doing so and it's just a very
timid uh uninquisitive group of people
and uh and they're uniquely ill-suited i
think to the mission of
trying to oppose this thing but you're
absolutely right i hadn't thought about
those other
other layers but they're yeah those will
probably come into play as well
they they will if they need to you know
it'll stop short of them if it can do it
with the other layer but the problem is
you know you say exactly the right thing
it hasn't been necessary yet but the
same principle applies as soon as it's
necessary it will be too late right you
have to see it coming and
what you describe in journalism uh i
call the epidemic of cowardice
but it's also a kind of learned
helplessness and
that's exactly what i saw in academia
and i think
the problem is it's civilization-wide
that our developmental environment has
cultivated these weaknesses and now they
are being exploited
i think not for nothing a lot of people
are saying
this is the evergreen of the united
states right now
your story is kind of the great metaphor
for
all of this stuff um and
you know the i remember if i remember
correctly there was that vote initial
vote where
you objected to that one provision
whether i guess they were asking you to
put down on paper your thoughts about
equity diversity inclusion or something
like that right no it was to reflect
on our own progress relative to our
internal racism
annually in a document that was then
going to go into our file
first of all i i just can't even imagine
being a person and thinking that
like that would be a good idea and
for a variety of reasons putting any of
that down on paper for was
but anyway the the notion that the vote
ended up being 70 to 2 or whatever it
was
um you know that kind of speaks to all
the things that are going on now in
in the press we you hear a lot from
journalists who are saying you cannot
believe what's going on in our shop
right now right or
um they're meeting they're meeting out
after work
in bars uh sometimes people are only
willing to talk about what's going on at
work if they work with their spouses
right so this is again recall's the kind
of the soviet
uh cliche of the husband and wife who
spoke under the covers at night you know
about what was going on at work
um you know that stuff's going on in
this business now
and um yeah i mean that the the problem
is that
people keep thinking that it's not going
to come for them that if they just go
along that eventually
like they'll get to keep their job and
you know
it's not going to be a problem but it
eventually it does you know it's it
sniffs you
out uh and
people are mistaken if they think
they're not going to end up having to
collide with it at some point or another
yeah eventually it's going to come for
you and eventually is like
by the end of july right yes exactly
exactly so here's the thing you're right
everybody
you can imagine how many people are
telling me my god we're all evergreen
now right
it's like okay yes you are now can we go
the next step
and it's like i just i want
just emblazoned the word extrapolate
right on something that i can hold in
front of people because the point is
okay
if this is evergreen and it is i mean um
the parallel is almost
too close to believe right if this is
evergreen
what happens next i mean first of all
look at evergreen right
evergreen is a failing college it has a
quarter of the students it's supposed to
have it has no plan
going forward and it has continued down
this road without ever acknowledging it
made a mistake
right that's the that's the democratic
party
right joe biden is george bridges
and the united states is about to be
evergreened except
that in the united states there's
another force that this is going to
collide with
which is the well-armed rural population
that has a right to be terrified that
this is coming for it
right yeah i saw a news article
yesterday that
not only are gun sales going up but that
40 of the sales are for
for first-time buyers um which i thought
was
pretty amazing statistics because
because we've seen
in the past you know various moral
manias that come up in the press
convince people to go out and buy guns
but it's usually the people who are
already
the gun enthusiasts buying guns yeah
exactly this is this is something new
um i don't know what that means yet i
think i think you're probably on to
something
uh that people are are gearing up
for some kind of conflict that they
imagine will happen which i i hope it
doesn't but
um but yeah absolutely there's that
and the the only thing i would push back
on with with
the metaphor of biden as bridges
is that you know
for all the craziness of all of this uh
you know trump is an extraordinarily
ineffective
vehicle for uh harnessing
the discontent uh and anger towards
um towards all of these processes he did
he did fairly well with it i would say
um
just cynically watching him in 2016 but
he was an unknown quantity then
and his total his incompetence to deal
with
you know this unique crisis that we're
in right now
is um i mean obviously i'm not gonna
make the same mistake of predicting
again uh that it's gonna he's going to
lose but it
you know it's very possible that bite is
going to win and even though
the democratic party is
intellectually i think it's just
completely broken it doesn't stand for
anything
anymore except for not being something
else
uh and even that doesn't stand for that
all that strongly
uh it could still sputter on for a
little while
um and what i guess what i worry about
is that it
it will succumb to the same
institutional pressures that
happen at evergreen and and have
happened more recently at the new york
times
it's you know it doesn't know
because it's not strong in its own
identity it's susceptible to being taken
over
by zealots uh and i don't know how
much you would worry about that but i
worry about that a little bit oh i think
it's
far worse than that yeah
this is becoming a theme i guess but the
uh the democratic party
stands for nothing because it has become
an influence peddling racket
as the republican party is and
as such the only thing it does
is protect its access to power and what
has happened is it has lost its argument
for being awarded that power by voters
and what it is now going to do
is it is going to rally a constituency
by giving it something real but what
it's giving it
is power over other citizens in other
words
and this is why i say it is george
bridges right
joe biden is the george bridges play
because what it's going to do
is it's going to empower this
counter-revolution
that is now marching in our streets and
marching in every single institution
it is going to empower them to keep them
from going after
the real culprits so right you know the
anger in the streets is about something
real
americans have been frozen out of a
large fraction of the well-being that
they have created
and in an effort to stave off the french
revolution
yet one more election cycle the
people with the pitchforks and the
torches are going to be awarded
rights to extract stuff from other
citizens
and that is what's i just don't even see
how that will be avoided it's not that
the zealots will take over the
democratic party
it's that the democratic party will
foolishly empower them
will cynically empower them in order to
win this election and potentially future
ones and that will be
the final straw yeah i think you're
probably right
uh i remember in 2016 watching
um you know when bernie
was first becoming a thing and
it was surprising to see how well he was
i guess it wasn't surprising
you know because the democrats are their
message is just so unsuccessful when
they try to present it
um you know unvarnished in front of
audiences it's just amazing the lack of
response they get
uh so bernie starts doing well and
one of the first things that starts
happening is that the clinton campaign
starts dusting off the language of
campus intersectionality to go after the
sanders movement
uh which i thought was fascinating
because i had watched hillary do
exactly the opposite in 2008
when barack obama was the candidate you
know she was
basically trying to run as george
wallace in places like pennsylvania
now they they figured because this is
how they're wired that well let's just
go for whatever cynically
will get us through the night um bernie
is vulnerable
we'll call him a cis white man we'll get
all of our
uh our aides to whisper in the ears of
journalists at night uh hillary uh
publicly says things like
yes if we broke up the banks tomorrow
would that end racism
which was an extraordinarily effective
line because bernie didn't know how to
answer that for some reason
uh he was afraid of the connotation of
answering that
answering that charge and he backed off
from it
and that became successful and i think
that's that's the seat the
that was the seed of what you're talking
about where the trade for the democrats
became
all right so to resi to stop us from
having to deal with
uh offending all of our donors in the
health insurance industry
in the military industrial complex uh on
wall street
and this is our power base right this is
with and they and they
transparently if you talk to people in
the party they transparently see their
job as
finding the middle ground between
getting elected
and and making sure that the donors are
happy and their donors are
you know not people they're these big
institutions
so they saw that the way forward was
to start adopting the language of
wokeness um
i don't think at any level they ever
believed it
uh in any meaningful way um
but they and they did it again this year
even you know with bernie
um again but i think you're right i
think what they're going to end up doing
is rather than go forward with medicare
for all
or any other kind of serious structural
reform or breaking up the banks on wall
street or
any of the other things that that people
have been asking for
um they're gonna they are gonna give
them something i think they're gonna
give them this
institutional revolution that some
people are asking for
which conveniently
will exclude some of their biggest
donors from impact
for a while you know and uh i think
that's that's a good analysis but that
you that you have the situation
it troubles me that that uh
we don't see that in the press very much
uh
when when they're talking about what the
democrats are doing with this language
why is nancy pelosi um
you know dressing in kente cloth scarves
and you know they're participating and
they're talking about knocking down all
these
statues where only a few months ago they
were denouncing sanders on patriotic
grounds
as being a russian agent like they don't
see the contradiction there
it's just it's it's an odd thing yeah
it's odd
it again reminds me of those people
walking out to look at the fish flopping
on the
sea yes exactly well that perfectly
describes the democrats in like a
million ways
in a million ways right exactly um and
you know
uh of course in 2020 that just puts us
in
such an amazing bind because
nothing stands between us and
this revolution getting its every wish
which
you know i guess on the bright side
the fairy tales it's talking about
aren't going to function
so it's not going to be long-term
successful but it can
wreck everything in the process and you
know not only are americans depending on
all the things that's going to wreck but
the world
is depending on us to um
to keep it together because if we don't
i mean
look what we're doing to the
international pick yeah
that and also i think another
huge issue there is
uh what happens when we don't get a fake
trump
the next time what happens when we get a
real fascist
uh in response which for sure is going
to happen
uh if if things continue
in a certain direction right because if
trump for all of his
faults and their you could list them
from now until tomorrow he
he's everything that a lot of people
have said about him
his uh personality is sufficiently
disorganized
uh and and the inward focus
that he was never able to commit to any
policy
of any kind he was not even you know
even when he brought in steve bannon
which i thought was a dangerous moment
because it wedded
an actual strategic mind to
the horsepower political horsepower that
trump was capable of bringing
he just couldn't get along with that
person for very long trump is like
he's so profoundly insecure in his
relationships
that he can't he can't have any for any
extended period of time
so it prevented him from doing a lot of
the dangerous things that people
predicted that he would do
uh but there's gonna come a time when
someone
is going to is going to try to get
elected using the same formula that
trump used but is going to be
not a dummy and not a narcissistic uh
you know sort of psychological uh
psychologically disabled person
and you know that's going to be a
serious problem right because there's
there's
all those people who are buying guns for
the first time
you know they're going to be receptive
to the message that comes from
you know the the face in the crowd andy
griffith figure who's
inevitably becoming inevitably going to
rise from all this
oh i exactly agree with this analysis
that uh as
troubling as trump is the fact that
you know he's a narcissist or the
equivalent
um actually limits the damage
right because you know his objective
function is not
uh to turn us into something
else he's you know he's not an organic
fascist he's
uh he's selfish right um and so
yeah this is coming and it's like
somehow we're having
this incredibly foolish argument where
people see
that they don't want trump and of course
they are blinded by it and you know
trump derangement syndrome is
real right and it is the entire argument
for the democratic party
winning at this point it's not a good
argument but
um but it's like
it's like quitting smoking right the
argument against quitting smoking cannot
be
it's very very hard to quit smoking
because it's going to get harder
right right so right if if trump is the
focus it's the only thing you can see
then the answer is well now is the time
we have to break out of this duopoly
nonsense because the next time it's
going to be way worse it's going to be
the thing you said it was this time that
it didn't turn out to be
right yeah absolutely and and and
if i could uh nerd out on the on the the
coverage of
of trump for a minute because this this
has bothered me a lot ever since he got
elected
the the storyline about trump
should have been the extraordinary black
comedy
that happened in 2016. like here was a
guy
who basically was not trying to win
who was running for a variety of reasons
that
were preposterous on like multiple
levels
who was actively sabotaging himself uh
multiple times throughout the campaign
and yet he wins anyway right like in
other words he's he's trying to lose but
america
does not let him lose and
rather than focus on
my god how could that possibly have
happened like how
what like profound structural flaws
in our system uh what could possibly
have disenchanted people so much that
they would even
override trump's natural
self-destructive urges to put him in
office um nobody did that analysis they
immediately
went for this other thing which was to
portray trump as something that he
wasn't which was this sort of
otherworldly hitlerian uh existential
threat who was you know any minute now
going to be putting us all in
concentration camps or surrendering us
to russia
which created this air of unreality
around everything
um and i think like like all
mislead like sort of journalistic
efforts to um to try to
put paint trump in a bad light they went
too far
and ultimately did damage to their own
cause in doing so you know i
like they they discredited themselves by
painting trump with something
that he isn't like the entire argument
for donald trump now
is the best argument is that
institutional america has lied about him
and he's if he if he ends up getting
elected again it'll be because of that
uh anyway that's that's a it's a
private thing that really really bothers
me about that that whole
narrative is that um you know
they got him elected the first time and
they're gonna do it again if it happens
again
oh i completely agree with this to the
extent that you have trump derangement
syndrome you should be looking at the
democratic party and saying how could
you have done this to us and how could
you possibly put us in danger of this
again
right there are actually two arguments
for trump now
one is that he has faced a conspiracy to
eliminate him from office from day one
which is true and i'm not saying
that there was nothing to the
impeachment i think there was but the
point is they would have impeached him
whether or not there was
right it was impeachment first and then
let's find grounds
um so that's one thing but the other
thing is by delivering us
joe biden as the alternative joe biden
in his enfeebled state they have created
another argument a rational person
could say well at the end of the day i
want somebody in the oval
office who is capable of processing the
information necessary
to let's say avoid a nuclear conflict
i don't want it to be trump because he
could get us into a nuclear conflict
on the other hand joe biden two years
from now as compared
to donald trump two years from now who
is going to be more capable of
integrating
information i can't say that i think
it's joe biden
maybe i can say that i think that there
he's going to step down but then the
point is
since when is electing a president
really a means of getting a vice
president
into the presidency uh you know this is
party rule
so i think that you know i i'm certainly
not voting for trump
i'm also not voting for biden but i can
see
now the democrats have created arguments
for voting for trump
and that ought to tell us something is
way off
yeah yeah i think i think you're you're
exactly right
uh if the pandemic hadn't happened i
would be betting
a lot of money on trump to win oh yeah
um
the the um his inability to deal with
this
well you know all of his worst qualities
have come out here
and so you know that they're going to
they're going to make the argument that
yeah well joe biden is basically a
corpse
and we all understand that and that's
why we're not going to put him on
television at all if we can avoid it
but we're really electing the people
behind him
uh and those people are going to you
know be relatively sane
which is going to be a new thing for
this country uh you know
at least for going back four years so
they're gonna make that argument but uh
you know
for a lot of people for for a lot of
voters
they don't think you know that many
levels down
they look at what the images they see on
television
and biden next to trump you know it
it it doesn't look great you know to the
ordinary voter
so uh yeah you're right
uh it's it's very frustrating that they
have that they've created this condition
again
yeah so let's talk a little bit about um
what we should do and what we might do
one thing i wanted to go back a little
bit in our conversation and talk about
if we look at the fact that they're all
of these layers where we have a
vulnerability
and these layers can be triggered if the
institutional layer fails to
create the requisite power that the
movement wants it can be the
payment layer or it can be the isp net
neutrality layer
but there are a lot of places one thing
that we should say
is if you were smart you'd build
now right so cryptocurrency for example
provides a solution to the payment layer
but you want to build it now the problem
with crypto or at least one of them
is that it's not simple enough for it to
simply
replace a compromised credit card layer
it needs it needs to be that simple in
order for it to actually constitute a
solution
um and the other thing is you have to
figure out how you're going to navigate
the internet without the major platforms
which have organized it for us
and given us access in a way that is
fundamental to how we actually use it
but it's a faustian bargain because it
gives them control over
who has access and you know it's in this
murky gray area where
you know it's like a public utility
except
uh it isn't right so anyway we should be
building those things now
rather than waiting to discover that
those layers are insecure
because they're definitely insecure and
it's definitely coming and it's marching
faster than we think
which we can extrapolate from everything
we've seen so far
we've just gotten there very quickly
yeah
so anyway i don't know there's much more
to say except if we were smart we'd be
building those
uh alternative plans now rather than
assuming
you know are crossing our fingers or
whatever it is that we're doing yeah i i
you know
i i've never been very much in the
solutions business i'm always much more
into describing the
the actual misery that's happening uh
side of things but the
um but yeah clearly
uh people definitely need to start
thinking about whatever
the alternative structures um
might be and you know
one thing that gives me i'm not going to
use this word because it triggers you
clearly is hope uh
you know it's the uh i remember during
the
more or less ineffectual uh occupy wall
street movement but one thing that did
come out of that
was a lot of thinking about well if we
don't want
uh an oligopoly of massive transnational
banks running the
the economy what what do we want uh
and there there were some ideas that
came out of that
um public banking some of some of the
cryptocurrency stuff
came out of some of the problems uh that
took place
um you know there were people who were
pushed in that direction i know
by by some of the events in 2008 um
so maybe that will happen here too like
the
there there'll be a political crisis
that will
cause a bunch of people to get together
and i know i mean i know you've got
a political solution that you've been
that you've been pushing which i i think
is great
um but clearly after the spectacle of
2016
people are going to be very ready for
some kind of alternative political
movement
in a way that they probably haven't been
in this country for
uh for a very very long time so it's
it's it's probably a good time for
people to get those ideas ready for vote
for mass
presentation uh it seems well i agree
it's
it's a good idea to to you know to
sketch those things out
for the moment at which they could be
introduced but i'm very concerned
that there's a there's just a general
pattern where you have
two things fused together right this
movement is
an organic rebellion against a corrupt
system
and it is a uh
a coup in one and
you know the organic rebellion doesn't
really understand that the coup
is not about making things better it's
about taking power
and that's what all of these uh false
syllogisms are about that it portrays
but i think the problem is
a this is occupy 2.0 but it's not
the occupy that started after the
financial collapse and had
legitimate complaints and had some idea
what direction it wanted to go with
structural change
it's what it's the it's picked up from
the end of occupy which was
thoroughly infused by this anarchism um
and this belief that the structure has
to be torn down
in order to make a new one and of course
that that is an argument being deployed
by people who i don't think
know anything about how international
relations work
how a nuclear reactor functions that a
nuclear reactor requires
power 24 hours a day seven days a week
and you can't screw that up for even a
day without it turning into a nuclear
volcano
right people who don't understand what
the haber bosch process is and what it
has to do with
beating more than half the world's
population so the idea of tear it down
is a very naive one
and it is now gaining power at amazing
at an amazing rate
and so those solutions you're talking
about i'm
on this path i don't see how they
actually end up in a position
to make positive change right yeah
well there are some general ideas that
might
that that would help right so one of the
things i like about your
unity idea is that
um it it sort of introduces the idea
of politics as not
a purely adversarial process right
that this is uh
this is something where you would get a
bunch of people in a room and they would
have to come up with a
a thing that they would agree on in a
collaborative way
which is what congress used to be right
i mean you if you talk to people in
congress i've done a lot of reporting on
congress where they
they talked about how in the 60s and 70s
um it was a much different situation
the politicians would get up and give a
speech on friday
but then on saturday the republicans and
democrats their families would get
together
um you know they would sometimes play
golf sometimes do whatever it was and
they would actually work out
the thing and they would sort of
patriotically have in mind
how that works and that all started to
break down in the 90s
and everything became you know
just shouting at each other the media
has broken down in the same way
right like so now it's just basically
two camps of
monocultures that are yelling at each
other uh
i think there's a strong urge and you
and you talk about this
in this the stats that you cite about
how people self-identify politically
if you could just attach um
a political idea to
[Music]
or express it in a way that all those
people who identify as independents and
don't identify as
you know far left far right could have a
place where they could
you know vote and and put somebody in
power i think it would be very very
successful
um but again i'm the optimist in this
conversation so well here here i like
your optimism a lot
um yeah the thing is we know i mean
you can intuit if you talk to people but
we now know from careful study
that the vast majority of americans
actually agree
and that this is the fringes driving
the discussion and most of us don't
sign up for either of the perspectives
that we see being broadcast at such high
decibel level
so yes that constituency it were you
to try to make a political move the
obvious way to win
every election is to agree to represent
the american public
right that's a slam dunk as the strategy
goes now the reason that our parties
never find that strategy is they can't
it's it's mutually exclusive with their
business model right exactly
of course you have it's your it's your
uh stock and trade or at least one of
them but
um but here's the question
what stops i mean look occupy in my mind
did one useful thing
really just one but it was important
and it was the idea that there was
something that you could even plausibly
describe
the conflict as between the one percent
and the 99 percent
how does the democracy get rigged
against 99 percent of its population
right that tells you it's not a
democracy it tells you some other force
has taken over
so um the point is
you can't interfere you can't honorably
interfere
in a normal election cycle because
you're told that if you do
if you try to represent the people and
get elected on that basis that you will
elect
the party that is less in line with your
values rather than more so
you're going to do more harm than good
because of the lesser evil paradox
so unity 20 20 20
addresses that so that we don't have to
face the lesser evil paradox and we can
reach the public and say look we've got
a plan for actually having your interest
represented at the highest level of
government which frankly i see as the
only thing
that could conceivably uh head off the
calamity to which we are currently aimed
but that requires
this other thing that we talked about
earlier to
somehow be knocked out of its normal
pattern of resonance which is to say
that same pattern
of cowardice and uh of passivity
basically i see it as people having been
turned
in their own minds from being
citizens into being consumers you know a
citizen is an active thing
a consumer is a passive thing and
because people
consume everything including the
political landscape they don't
understand that actually
the thing that is necessary to escape
the trap that has been set for them
in which they will vote for one or the
other terrible and highly corrupt
options is that they have to actually
take
ownership of the choice to do something
different
they have to figure out how to talk to
their friends for example right um
so i don't know um you know you're
you're
an interesting guy and i i wanna i wanna
find out a little bit about
how you ended up there we know a little
bit about your
background in russia which i think gave
you a very different
perspective on the west but it is also
the case
that your focus as a journalist
has created immensely powerful enemies
where it has put you in their sights
yeah right that's true
um yeah and and yet here you are that's
a little bit surprising
so you have beaten the odds in a way few
journalists
have been able to by reporting
accurately
and courageously on
phenomena that are deeply embarrassing
to the most powerful forces
in our system and you have stayed
you've stayed afloat so a
do you know how that happened
uh well you know in terms of
why you do that um you know my again my
my father was a journalist um
and i i grew up in an atmosphere my
childhood was a lot like the movie
anchorman
uh i you know he was a tv reporter
all the bad facial hair everything but
reporters when i was growing up
they came from a different class of
people than they do today they were um
a lot of them were kind of more working
class like they were more
likely their parents were more likely to
be plumbers or electricians than they
were to be
doctors or lawyers like the this thing
where
you know the journalist is uh an ivy
league grad that's a relatively new
thing that i think came up came about in
the 70s and 80s with my
generation but reporters basically just
instinctively hated
rich people they hated powerful people
like if you put up a
poster of a politician in the newsroom
it was defaced instantaneously like
there were darts on it you know
the the reporters saw it as their job
to stick it to the man right like that
was the
that was the attitude i think it's very
ably embodied by people like sai hirsch
if you've ever
seen him in public like that's just the
person who just lives to make people
uncomfortable
right uh and by digging and digging and
digging
and so that was the ethos that i grew up
around uh
and i always understood it
the purpose of the job to be to look in
all
directions and say like where's the
biggest most obnoxious thing that's
happening right now
and um you know what
well how can i have an impact that other
reporters maybe aren't paying attention
to
you know and so you know with something
like the the financial crisis in 2008
one of the first things that i learned
about that is that
the only people who are covering wall
street were
sympathetic to wall street because
nobody else understood it right so that
there was a an opportunity there to to
do this kind of work where we're just
basically translating things for
ordinary people and that's
very revelatory but uh
that that mode of of understanding the
job to be that
and being willing to take all the crap
that comes with it
um it used to be i think standard
in in the profession and i i don't
really
see that so much anymore although there
are a lot of people who
who are coming up who um
you know are that way you know people
like lee fong at the intercept
glenn greenwald is different he's like
you come from the reporting tradition
but
he's got that same personality quirk of
just wanting to piss people off
uh but mostly the the job is different
now right like i think the have you ever
seen movie primary colors
um it was the sort of it was sort of a
book that was made into a movie
but uh it was about the clinton campaign
in 1992
it was written by journalist named joe
klein who initially was anonymous
wrote it as a novel but the the fantasy
among reporters in the in the 90s about
politicians started to be
i want to be the person who hangs out
with the candidate
after the speech and has a beer and it's
sort of close
to power and that's that's kind of the
model
that's where we're at right now that's
kind of the problem is
is that basically people in the business
want to be behind the rope line
with uh people of influence and
um you know it's going to be it's going
to be a problem trying to get us back to
other adversarial posture
in the past yeah i agree and in some
sense
i mean that that's important history and
i think it's
uh it's useful insight and i'm glad to
hear it but
you know it is the easier part of the
puzzle i understand
why you would want to do what you do
what i don't understand is
how you've succeeded at it just as with
institutions we see
there's almost not an institution and
maybe really not an institution that has
shown us
how to resist this movement there's very
little indication
that what you do is possible which is to
confront
these very powerful entities and live to
tell the tale and not be
driven off the map or co-opted or i
don't know what
well i mean i i've definitely been you
know
bruised a little bit over the years i've
gone i've gone through a couple episodes
that haven't been all that pleasant but
i think if you
you know in terms of um
what i've done to try to
retain an audience over the years um
there's only a couple of ways to really
do it you either have to do what psy
hirsch does
which is get get the story that no one
else can get
um and that that's just
you know a way of amassing power in this
business right like
you have something that no one else has
people are gonna come to you no matter
what
and incidentally he's basically been
driven out of the business if you notice
he only publishes in like the london
review of books now
um and you know this is the person who
from eli to
to abu ghraib has always gotten the
biggest story right so
there's there's even for the best of us
it's a very difficult road uh but the
other way to do it i think is the way
that i
um and i take probably the easier road
which is just
you know i focus a lot on trying to make
the work
entertaining uh clear
and and have some kind of popular appeal
to it
which is very difficult to
suppress right so if you if people just
if you're got a little bit of humor um
you know it's difficult to get to get
people to stop
reading something that they just enjoy
reading
you know and so uh that
mixed with being super careful about the
investigative stuff like you don't wanna
you know in this business one bad
mistake
that labels you as dishonest
um is usually fatal or it used to be
anyway so that's been my that's been my
formula is like be
be really really careful and then try to
try to think
in terms of how you really really think
in terms of rhetorically how to reach
a wide audience which is a lot harder
than people think it is it's
it's a very difficult thing to do um but
you know that's the job right i mean so
um
it's i've been lucky that that also that
there
there are um processes like
you know this subscription site that i
have available now
that make it possible to be a little bit
braver than maybe a
would be if i was only working in an
institution but um
but there is a way forward to do it it's
just it's not terribly easy that's all
all right so there are a couple lessons
in there that i resonate with strongly
one is you've built this site outside
of your day job as it were at rolling
stone
and i believe this is actually a
fundamental
mechanism for surviving in this era
because
if your own if everything if your
mortgage your health care
your retirement your income
if all of that stuff comes through your
employer
and something catches the attention of
your employer and decides to go after
you
then you have very few options whereas
if you have built something on the
outside ahead of time
then the point is well you may not want
to lose your day job
but at least you're not starting from
scratch at the point that you do
so this was true for heather and me when
we got driven out of evergreen which is
that we were already
um we were not well known but we were
already reaching out and trying to
figure out how to bring
evolutionary biology to a wider audience
and it made a huge difference because we
were not
at square one right um the other thing
you mentioned which i think may be
in some sense the most important factor
in
all of this is i think you have pointed
to a conspicuous
lack of humor of the movement
it's amazing actually it's amazing
yeah and it is i think it is the thing
that frightens me
most yeah you know i have this this when
students used to ask me they asked me
for advice about all sorts of things
because at evergreen
we knew our students really really well
so many of them were
friends at one level or another and i
used to tell them
uh you should not consider
marrying anyone who does not have a
sense of humor about themselves
they're just not marriage material um
right because you're going to need the
sense of humor everybody's got to have a
sense of humor about themselves just to
navigate something as complex as
marriage
anyway that's an aside about marriage
but the point is
the lack of a sense of humor on the part
of this movement
tells you something about a kind of um
rigidity of thinking
and a i don't know what it is but it's
it's a very
old frightening uh absence
yeah and once you spot it you can't miss
it oh you're absolutely right
i just wrote about this uh last week
actually
that you know the the 60s liberation
movements
um they had this enormous
power uh to spread
because they were incredibly attractive
to people even even who were politically
resistant
to them the music was great the comedy
was amazing like even people who were
abject racist they listened to richard
pryor's comedy and they
they couldn't help themselves they
laughed right and
and i think it was because that movement
was very much
about celebrating the common humanity
of people they were trying to dig down
and
and
get to deeper truths about all of us and
even if it was kind of
uh disturbing and unpleasant like they
were gonna
put it out there and um and that was
really liberating for everybody and it
was a very attractive
message you know i think that's what i
was trying to do is contrast that with
this
which has no art no no music
no certainly no comedy right there's
the the there's no such thing as comedy
and in this conception it's actually
it's almost definitionally impossible
because
comedy by its nature is daring and it's
iconoclastic in all directions right the
the the urge to be funny always ends up
dressing down
everybody not just a specific target uh
you know it's not just the emperor who
has no clothes it's everybody right so
uh when you're trying to have a very
didactic politics comedy just doesn't go
well with it you know
and um and that's a conspicuous weakness
of this movement
i i think a lot about there was a book i
read a long time ago
it was a biography of lenin called the
bolsheviks that was written by this
historian adam ulam
who is a very funny writer
himself but he was obsessed with lenin
and it shines through in the book that
the thing
it's almost an admiration like he was he
was
amazed by the scale of lenin's
humorlessness
uh and and he he was almost like a
a 700 page ode to a person who was
incapable of
laughing right uh and that feels a
little bit like what
we're dealing with with a lot of this
new ideology like you
you just can't believe that in any in
every direction you look there's
there's no possibility of like any kind
of relief or looseness or anything it
just gets
it gets tighter tighter so uh
it's fascinating you know and also it's
weird because young people by their
nature want a joke
and and they don't you know uh and i i
don't
i don't know where it leads honestly
it's it's strange
well so i have an evolutionary take on
this which is good
um humor is actually a mechanism
whereby we discover
what hangs out on the fringes of our
consciousness
you know if somebody makes a joke and
it reveals if people laugh and it's
organic laughter rather than that stupid
applause that you
see people do these days when somebody
makes a joke if they
earnestly laugh you can actually tell
that they know the truth of that
statement
right and it may be it may not be a
straightforward truth but there's some
truth in it and they know it and you
know it and now you both know that each
other knows it right so
um evolutionarily humor is like a
mechanism for exploring
things that are at the fringes of
consciousness
often because they're a bit
uncomfortable right so it's like
signing on to an acknowledgement that
yeah we all know that thing is true
right
um and so the flip side of this is
if your movement is composed at least at
the level
of what it claims of pure nonsense
a humor is almost inconceivable because
humor would reveal that you know how
feeble these arguments are or you don't
and that makes you even more of a fool
right right so the point is we're not
going to even allow
joking because if we allow joking that'd
be it
might be over in an hour you know yeah
um so
that's the frightening thing is that the
humorlessness kind of goes along with a
power grab that cannot afford
to be candid cannot afford for anybody
to be candid about what they see and
know about how it functions and what
it's after
um yeah you're absolutely right but
that's i think it's a huge weakness
though
of this thing because people just
they just can't go for long without
laughing at something you know um
and this uh
this movement has gotten progressively
more and more
uh constrained and paranoid and unable
to
uh have any kind of sense of humor about
itself
you know even even like commercial
humor like the saturn outline version of
humor
um it was bad enough when
basically all the jokes that you saw on
television
were putin coming down the chimney or
some other thing where there's like a
overt lead in political message attached
to it
but you don't even really get that
anymore like there's there's just
not even an attempt and um you know
people want something eventually
somebody is going to be
brave and funny enough to come up and
just
rip through it the way richard pryor did
you know like there's going to be just a
genius
uh you know a lenny bruce type who's
going to take advantage
of the this constricted atmosphere
and uh and it's i think that's going to
be devastating to it
you know once the right comedian mixes
with this material which is amazing
material
uh it's going to be devastating yeah i
think i think we can say two things for
sure one you just said which is that
somebody is going to figure out how to
do this and it's going to be devastating
and the other thing we can say is that
it's going to be dave chappelle
yes that's true that's true yeah you can
tell i mean he
he's he's the perfect person to do it uh
and he's uncancelable um
so yeah i think we await uh with
interest
to see how how he but you know he's
going to have to commit to it when he
does it too you know what i mean it's
going to have to be
an ongoing like slugfest so yeah
personally i'm hoping that his august
calendar is clear for that job because i
don't know how much longer
we can hold out
absolutely yep all right so uh before we
close this out is there anything you
think we should cover
i mean i'd love to have you back anytime
you want to come but
anything you think we should cover today
no i think we went we went through most
of it i mean uh honestly
i'm i you know i was going to ask you
a few things on it because uh i'm
starting to
sort of lose a lot of the origins of
this stuff
and um you know one thing i'm really
interested in
um is like the proliferation
of administrative staff and what when
that started
like why do you think that that happened
like
so i've had some people suggest to me
that
university suddenly became awash in
money because of
guaranteed student loans or whatever it
was like
where did all these extra people come
from and
uh what's what's worth looking at if i
was you know
going to try to look at the origins of
that yeah i think
george bridges actually taught me the
answer to this and
i'm trying to figure out whether you
know he and i had a very adversarial
relationship but it involved a certain
number of private conversations in which
there was more candor than you might
imagine
and you know he was the worst offender
in this regard he brought in
he massively increased the size of the
administration of the college and he
boosted some people to positions of
power who
weren't qualified for it didn't bring
anything to the table that
would make you want them in those
positions and
it became clear that in some sense he
was
building a structure that was
self-protected
a you know you can imagine you take
somebody
who you know i don't know maybe they're
earning
you know fifty thousand dollars a year
and suddenly
you get them a job where they're earning
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year
right that's going to be a loyal person
when your malfeasance come to the
surface that's somebody who's going to
stand by you
right so i think the general rubric was
in george's case he was solving a george
problem and the george problem was he
was going to do some
stuff that was going to put him in
jeopardy he needed people who could be
sacrificed and a large number of them so
that as people came for him
you know heads could roll and they
wouldn't be his
and he needed to have more votes than he
had
and the way you get more votes is you
get people who you know
uh will clarence thomas to your antonin
scalia
right so um i don't know
how general it is but i guess i would
say game theoretically
i think the basic answer is much of what
goes wrong
goes wrong because individuals are
serving a narrow individual purpose
and we look at the collective
consequence of this and imagine that an
institutional purpose
is being solved right right interesting
so that's that's my best guess the other
thing is
actually this is something um uh
at some point i had dinner heather and i
did with jordan peterson and he
said that he had seen this phenomenon
which i'm sure you're going to be as
familiar with
as anybody which is that you you have an
institution and it's constructed
to solve a problem but over time it
evolves
to continue to exist that becomes its
purpose
and so lots of things that are designed
to accomplish some goal
subtly shift to actually not solving the
problem because
that would be reason to go extinct
right and rather than do that they come
up with self-justifying
explanations for the need to have them
go on forever and you know you can even
hear this in this movement
about how uh you know
this contradiction white supremacy
is a terrible critical problem in the
united states
that requires us to address it
immediately and in profound ways
it's also an incurable problem so
there's really no point in addressing it
we will be doing this forever right it's
a
lifetime commitment yeah it's a
permanent job
it's the goal we will never reach right
so
anyway i think this um
this this tendency for things that have
gained power gained access to resources
to come up with reasons that they need
to continue doing what they're doing
has more to to say about why
these administrations become bloated now
why it suddenly took off
clearly there was some sort of a tipping
point or phase transition
that gave whatever it is that wants to
create more
administration the power to do so um
and it's a little harder to spot what
that might be
um but somewhere in that neighborhood
the game theory
is happening at the individual level and
the analysis is happening at the
collective level and so they
they don't meet right right another
point she'll meet right but interesting
all right well cool um brett thank you
so much
uh for having me on i really appreciate
it well i really appreciate you coming
on
i do want to ask it just straight out
sure um
will you join us unity2020 yeah
you indicated that you like the plan but
frankly the problem is
many people don't know what to make of
it and for
matt taivi to say that he sees what it
is
understands its importance and uh
supports it
would i think go a long way to
convincing people that this is
um this is not performance art this is
actually an attempt to
um to write our course and preserve the
republic
and uh you know the most serious of
people
take it seriously no i i love the idea i
signed the
the petition on the way this morning or
uh
so uh great yeah yeah well thank you so
much we really appreciate that
and um you know i'm already looking
forward to our next conversation
absolutely let me know anytime and we
should come on our show sometime too
i would love to um before we sign off
completely
people can find you on twitter at your
uh
yeah i'm at mtybee and that's t-a-i-b-i
my site is taibi.substance.com
and then i'm at rollinstone.com as well
all right
now i would personally add that uh i
have signed up for
your site and i've been blown away by
the quality of your writing and the
clarity of your thinking and
uh you know there are a limited number
of dollars that you can throw at
signing up for stuff but this is highly
worth it i would put it at the top of my
list
outstanding well i i i appreciate that
uh
normally i wouldn't be uh mentioning
that but
in this climate i i actually do need the
subscriber support so thanks very much
well
let's let's not be embarrassed about
that this is something i've learned a
bit
from my brother which is look if you
want this kind of stuff
to happen in an environment where
institutions are toppling at the rate
they are
then you got to support it and the fact
is you know you have three kids am i
right yep that's right yes
you've got a family you have to support
them they have to come first and yet
you're
courageously uh exploring this stuff as
you have been for decades
so um you know we can all feel good
about supporting you
and i certainly do and i know that that
my viewers will as well
outstanding thanks so much but i
appreciate it and all right talk again
soon
yeah thanks matt all right be well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you